foreign
[Music]
bad kisser kept licking my neck like an
animal grooming its kid York couldn't
finger properly he bit my [ __ ]
pour up a body strength so we kept
leaning on my breasts for support
that that's jokes
some of the descriptive words people opt
to use it is so painful to annihilate
the male species or upper body strength
I can't even imagine bro oh that oh
that's poor that's for [ __ ] harsh he
had to lean on my breasts for support
while banging Mish oh [ __ ] sake open
his eyes when kissing
yuck to be fair she said zero foreplay
not even kissing stuck it in me and
asked me why I'm tight and dry that's
right excuse me
[ __ ]
shoved it inside why why are you why are
you tired and why are you dry
don't you know we're having sex
I'm clearly yeah
Play Your Part [ __ ] Play Your Part
this chick Puck couldn't take
constructive criticism
I just want the laughing emoji
um sometimes it is tough to be fair I it
defend it yeah it depends on what
someone's definition of constructive
criticism is because there's there's not
subjective I don't mind instructional
stuff if it's like a Harder Faster
slower left right yeah right there yeah
right there right there right that is
what I like yeah come on yeah that's
something but if it's like a look
you seem to think that I enjoy this and
I'm not sure why I don't know what those
other [ __ ] like but this is painful
so if you could just you know like stop
doing that yeah and actually like learn
how to [ __ ] that would be great
yeah she wouldn't make it halfway
through sentence before I'm soft that's
too much talk yeah that's two I mean
Dick's inside and you're talking way too
much that's all I'll be thinking you're
talking way too much my dick's inside
you you shouldn't you shouldn't be able
to talk like this you should be able to
make making these cognitive yeah yeah
sentences yeah you shouldn't be able to
flow your way through a sentence like
this you're too coherent I don't like it
I generally don't like it that's true
um one checkbook he doesn't give head
and I think that's so poor
it is so poor it is poor
um it is actually poor like it it needs
to get sussed and addressed because I I
just don't understand uh obviously back
we've spoken about this before I think
on the last more maybe the last YouTube
episode before about giving head back in
the day in school and stuff like how we
said uh if you're in a secondary school
we can never say oh you were giving head
blah blah obviously that was then like
this is now regardless of the age of
whoever sent this in or whether the um
the guy is the recipient is
big man just get where it's 2022 like if
you're having sex just give head
literally your head it's not even it's
we're not asking yes you know they're
not asking for us we're not asking just
yeah just do what's up suck some dick
just give head like it's standard it's
so it's like your lips it is it is like
a lips at this point when I hear he or
she doesn't give head I literally hear
they don't kiss me before they [ __ ] me
and I'm like what are you talking about
literally what what are you actually
talking about like man it's it's it's uh
it's childish behavior man no wonder
women are sick of us this childish
behavior it is still
he tried to grip my neck and couldn't
gather the strength he started to shake
[Laughter]
he started to shake the muscle
contraction could he just couldn't
handle it anymore
and she's just like yawn
[Laughter]
grab me if you're gonna grab me [ __ ]
grab me be stronger
be a male [ __ ]
no waistline just in and out was
extremely boring
no foreplay lack of affection no girth
silence less than 10 minutes
for a bullet point bro no foreplay lack
of affection no girl she wrote silence
and capitals no girth no silence less
than 10 minutes
oh yeah that's not an experience mum
okay and this is a random realm this is
not much it's not round I don't know why
I said random because it's completely
relevant to this
um
what's a I think we've probably had this
conversation what's a good length of
time for four player for sex for actual
sex because right right
I'm talking about
sex like actual intercourse not
foreplay then intercourse then sucking
dick again and then a bit of finger in
and then [ __ ] again like that can go
on the whole hour yeah I'm talking about
from when I've given head you've given
head and I've stuck it in and I'm not
I'm not stopping yeah I'm only changing
positions yeah no one's given head
anymore yeah no one's giving head
anymore there's no pauses yeah no one's
pulling out no one's doing anything we
are actually [ __ ] now yeah
none of that yeah we are banging
from that point to nothing like what's
an actual nut not taking like this is a
good amount of time or a bad what's a
like
appropriate amount of time I would say
15 to 20. 15 to 20. I feel like 20 is
long because I I think about it I
compare it to other stuff okay like
watching a show like I I compare it to
like
how do I explain it
okay okay well let's not even not even
that other stuff but let's talk about
other physical activities okay
imagine 20 minutes of a football match
and you're one of eleven you're tired
yeah imagine it's just you yeah yeah
1v1 of anything for 20 minutes let's
just say uh uh boxing match oh there's
like three minute rounds we're talking
three minute rounds to get to 20 minutes
we're talking what
that's at least six rounds six seven
rounds six rounds six in a bit round
yeah do they get gaps in between yeah
that's a long time that is a long time
20 minutes yeah that's a different form
of example of course I'm not talking
about being tired I'm just saying but um
I feel like 20 minutes because I think
like what do I do for 20 minutes 20
minutes is a long time when you actually
sit there and actually cut it or
whatever yeah it is yeah yeah yeah
um and because we're stroking I'm
stroking at what
I'm talking
yeah let me find my Cadence yeah
I'm trying to find my my 20 minute case
because I've got different caters yeah
different different positions different
yeah this is like it's my four minute
Cadence
[Music]
20 minute Cadence
yes slow and deep it's low and deep it's
slow and deep I this is what's up
because I think I've got ADHD okay
because when I tell me I feel like I
know I've got ADHD because when you're
telling me 20 minutes and I'm thinking
of this Cadence
I'm thinking I'm so bored
because I can't keep that Cadence up for
long oh no neither could I we're gonna
have to go for it yeah yeah yeah and
yeah I'm Eva to be fair it depends on
what mindset I'm in if I'm trying to
leave an impression 20 minutes here
we're doing up down cadences we're doing
obviously bear positions and I'm trying
to aim we're trying to pattern a nut for
you like
once maybe twice before I'm before these
20 minutes are up but if we're just
going if this is the 19th time I've
banged you 20 minutes parmesan but
I promise John Boy
I haven't got time for that Cadence yeah
if we're we're in a relationship
basically yeah I haven't got time for
that Cadence
I'd rather go multiple rounds than do uh
like 20 half an hour yeah yeah I'm not
I'd like a wholesome between 7 and 13
minutes okay just banging yeah from yeah
other stuff we could be talking half an
hour 45
hour like max if I'm really really bad
like I've got some drink in my belly
yeah yeah yeah and time's flying but
yeah I'm talking if we're in a
relationship
okay seven to thirteen okay because yeah
yeah I like I wanna
I wanna catch you on your way out of the
toilet or something like that I want to
catch you doing up some dishes and this
is a little cool yeah cool six seven
minutes yeah yeah if it's bedtime I'm a
bit tired thirteen it's been a long day
yeah 13 I'm thinking we don't need to be
up all night like let's just that's
that's just not in case yes let's have a
good time yeah yeah 20 minutes to me is
I I will get bored okay
but I don't know I would still say 15 to
20 for you but I understand where you're
coming from
um
some ladies May disagree ladies in the
comments below let us know what you
thought obviously we're thinking of met
as men obviously ladies let us know what
you think is an appropriate time or
amount of time for just penetration yeah
and this is actual foreplay not a good
time not a bad time just an average
average appropriate time what you think
would be good for you
um so yeah let us know in the comments
um I think I've got one more all right
yeah sorry I forgot this is even oh it
wasn't a thread minor bro I loved
hundreds so I got three more
so the question again was sorry what
made him bad in bed
and
acting like my clip was the analog stick
on a PlayStation controller
just
didn't go down or foreplay stop three
times during sex because he was tired
and I thought and then patted himself on
the back when I came without his help
last one what does a pat on the back
look like in that scenario but he did
nothing
I don't know yeah I don't know I don't
know uh 20. 23 with erectile dysfunction
and was delusional about it
[Laughter]
delusional
swear damn erectile and was
delusional about it that's um bro but
yeah that's um was delusional about it
that's the thread about what made him
bad
[Music]